cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com we got some big news
this is from timcast.com woman who
burned down Wyoming abortion clinic
sentenced to five years in prison Lorna
Roxanne green was given the minimum
possible sentence for the arson laurebox
in green 22 a 22 year old this is Gen Z
received the minimum possible sentence
for the 2022 arson at Wellspring Health
Access in Casper
I'm sorry man look don't please please
we we don't do things like this you
should not do things like this we are
trying to avoid this we're trying to win
through the process by which the
founding fathers helped enshrine I
understand a lot of people are Gail the
founding fathers fought and did a lot of
stuff it's like dude they also fought to
create a system where we could with the
Constitution the Bill of Rights solve
these problems without having to that
was the whole point right that was the
whole point right representation fight
again they didn't want to fight in the
first place and that's right quite
literally the fighting was because they
weren't being represented we now have a
a crumbling fractured system but still
an opportunity it is not it is not done
impossible so please this one we should
not have done this but I bring the story
up because I have warned about this
we have we've seen it before the attacks
on abortion clinics and we've had the
conversation on this show
that when you start seeing uh States say
abortion to the point of birth and other
states say no abortion at all Oklahoma
and Colorado sharing a border this is an
inevitability now again
people should not be doing this okay you
it needs to be handled by by a law
enforcement Arbiter to shut these things
down through the vote and that's what
you're getting in the in in the states
that are passing the laws and they're
doing it by the book let them let the
left overreact and let the law take care
of it because that's the that's the
process by which we have agreed we can
get these things done
however
um it pains me to say man I I hate to
say I told you so and I think we're
going to see worse than this first of
all she's getting the minimum five years
in prison for burning down an abortion
clinic did she actually burn it down
well I mean I would assume if Cassandra
wrote it it burnt down did people get
hurt but she'd get murder charged stuck
inside absolutely absolutely yeah I I
don't think anybody was hurt because uh
that would change
that that would change the sentence
sentencing guidelines all together yeah
so yeah burning down is a is is a direct
statement that means it would totally
destroy the building but I'm not
entirely sure burn it Into Obscurity
into unrecognizability
well once you have a gas tank gas
canister or something gasoline yes in
this building so of course this will
also be weaponized by The Establishment
by the uh Democrats and government
absolutely they'll use this as a tool
they're going to run these commercials
in 2024 as uh why you have to vote for
us they're going to say far-right
extremists are doing this that are
otherwise
my point is not to bring that up my
point is simply to say people are on
edge and this stuff is happening but but
there is a better way to deal with this
issue there are very very uh strong
opinions on on both sides but
Republicans are not handling this issue
well at all they're not and they create
you know every once in a while there
needs to be a release valve in society
and public policy if something's not
going your way uh unfortunately can lead
to stuff like this Republicans know
where they have the country on abortion
and yet they just continuously overreach
I also want to make sure because this is
not just about Democrats it's the story
here from the post-millennial leader in
Richmond Democrat Party group arrested
after posting bomb threat against Andy
no in Virginia talk there's a big
difference between threatening someone
and then actually sneaking to a billion
setting on fire so I want to make sure
that's clear my point for this segment
is not to accuse one side of being worse
than the other these are two anecdotes
two extreme instances but it's it's it's
it's worrisome to see these kinds of
things happen there's there's already
heightened political tensions and now we
have
like bro these are these are young
people and they are just ruining their
lives they've lost their minds the
firebomb lawyers and mental illness is a
big problem to him after the uh the
summer of 2020 I'll accuse one side of
being worse than the other side no no no
no I agree with that no I'm saying right
now with these two articles oh okay I'm
not here to be like aha but look what
they left it no obviously a threat is
not as bad as actually burning a
building down you know I'm highlighting
these things to say there is conflict in
this country and people say things like
we're not in a civil war and it's like
civil Strife Stephen Marsh describes it
as civil Strife it's the period before
Civil War it's like Bleeding Kansas
perhaps that's where we're at I think
Portland is absolutely in a Bleeding
Kansas State where businesses are
fleeing flash mobs are destroying
everything like
people are are living in fear as crime
runs rampant far left extremists are
getting whatever they want just real
quick uh their antifa was marching down
through the streets with rifles stopping
traffic and controlling the controlling
vehicles in in Portland and in Seattle
with Chaz chop like it's it's happened
all over you were saying Rich about
mental health I fully agree mental
health is such a problem right now and
the health the degraded health of the
country the minds of the people but like
and earlier we were talking about
utilitarianism and how like you have to
decide as a government well how many
chickens have to die in order for how
many eggs to be laid okay you cannot
quantify mental health utilitarianly it
cannot be done and the government
attempting to
figure out what's wrong with individuals
by making blanket medications is like
not working it has not worked gun
violence is not has not gone down I
could not more strongly disagree that
the government should be in a position
to decide you know how many chickens
especially when the chickens are an
analogy for human beings the government
is in no position to decide what humans
should and should not live I mean this
goes back to the argument that Tim was
having with Sargon the other day about
about the death penalty or whether or
not it's it's legitimate or not and that
your opinion on that aside the
government is a result of the consent of
the people the government does not have
a the right to to make decisions about
the people the people make decisions for
the government and this is a fundamental
fundamental principle of a free Society
the government's legit intimacy comes
from the consent of the governed and it
does not cut the government does not
exist to inform the people how they
should think what they should believe or
how they should organize their lives
period the problem and maybe you're
right that it could that that's ideal
but is that people will have faith in a
government to govern people they don't
know and that they'll never meet and
they'll send their tax money to that
organization and that government has to
make decisions about where is the food
going to go this this month who's going
to get it who's not going to get it so
that's what I mean who's going to live
who's going to die they shouldn't be
made that's that's what a market is for
that's why we have that's why the
government shouldn't be involved in
markets but then you get a a individual
business leader deciding like Vanderbilt
no shut off the trains to New York City
no look at all the I mean right now
you're talking about you're you're
talking about you know who's going to
get food and stuff grocery stores are
all over the country people can decide
where to go on their own and we don't
need the government to tell us how to
live our life back before 1860
Vanderbilt he owned all the trains in
the country basically he ran the country
oh our arguably is the man who built
America Vanderbilt and he decided one
day he didn't like the way they were
treating him so he cut off access to New
York City he's like no you're not
getting trains in New York City anymore
until you until you meet my demands and
we realize how dangerous is to let the
private sector run I completely disagree
completely totally disagree with your
perspective and it is only the and if
you empower the government to do those
things then you are empowering the
government to decide who lives and who
dies who eats and who does not eat and
the gut and any government in history
that has had that power has abused it
and it turns into piles and piles and
piles of dead human beings let me just
because you got you you haven't gone so
far as to really argue the point of a
modern Democrat but what you guys are
arguing is a modern Democrat would say
but the government is the people and you
hear AOC actually say this all the time
absolutely not and I agree with you
right and to I would say in response to
what you're talking about because I get
it the Gilded era I get it
I would rather deal with the guild
than a government
that's just the way that that's where
I'm at the government has unlimited
power to coerce you to hurt you to you
know there's never going to be a guy
who's so rich he's going to be more
powerful than the Central Intelligence
Agency or the Federal Bureau of
Investigation I mean well not in this
Society you know maybe not in a true
market or something but they're not a
true market you know if we if we stuck
no you know to our uh original you know
if we stuck to our original design
original they there's I don't know why
they named it this now but
um as I did work on this for a book they
called it virtue capitalism like
somewhere along the lines
um we need to re-emphasize some virtues
that are about capitalism and to me and
it's like have you read Max vapor
the Protestant ethic and the spirit of
capitalism that's not capitalism so the
the pursuit of greed for greed's sake
has been around since Antiquity yeah and
communism too that's exactly right it's
everywhere it has nothing to do all
right so when a you hear AOC make those
points it's like well that's not what
capitalism is at its core and again uh
I'd I'd rather deal with a greedy fat
cat you know who's got competition with
monopoly laws you know anti-monopoly
laws things like that then a government
because somewhere along the line
Democrats started to believe what he was
arguing against what governments enforce
the ant the monopoly laws that's true
that's true but we're not talking about
to the point of that that's different
you have a justice system for that
that's of within reason we're not
talking about uh the ability to to chop
up I don't Parts I don't believe the
United States could be communist that's
why one of the reasons I think we're
winning I I think we can see communist
influence but the backlash that we're
seeing in response to a lot of this
stuff is the a natural reaction I don't
know about never but not now I think
never you think Never Never Say Never I
mean well like let's be realistic
nothing's absolute right for all we know
like a plague hits wipes up most of the
population and then a new civilization
number just calling it something that
says yeah there's a lot of circumstances
I'm saying based on the current
iteration of our government and our
culture today the systems that we have
in place uh in all likelihood will will
not right what about fascists see that's
I never I never liked when the right
always said no no Obama's a socialist
he's a
fascists with the Federal Reserve if you
look at if you look at the Soviet Union
if you look at communist China we may
get Civil War but I do not think we
would get you know a lot of people ask
us we'll say like is it a civil wars or
a Communist Revolution and will
interchange but let me let me break this
down and clarify when I'm when I'm
talking to my friend uh I was I was uh
visiting Ukraine covering some stories
there and the the apartment where we
stayed used to be Soviet communist
blockhousing and she explained how the
the apartment she was in back in the day
the two neighbors hated each other and
so one neighbor called the secret police
and said they were speaking bad about
the party the next day the apartment was
cleared out everything was gone that's
it neighbor taken care of that might
happen in U.S cities
but the the I do not believe that uh if
the United States ever went that kind
that to that degree of authoritarian it
would be ubiquitous outside of cities
for example when they did all the
coveted lockdowns
in most red areas nobody did anything
even when they had those rules a lot of
them did they don't have the means to
enforce it and when people are living
successfully out in the middle of
nowhere they're just going to do
whatever they want for the most part and
they do there are parts of West Virginia
where it's like sure you're supposed to
get a permit for that and then people
build whatever they want and everyone
just rolls their eyes because like what
are you gonna do you're you're 70 miles
from the nearest uh town this is one of
the things that affected West Virginia
when it came to uh this gun bill that
the Democrats wanted to do where it was
like you had to go all gun transfers
must be through ffls
because uh some guy pointed out that
he's in rural West Virginia with like
really crappy internet and the nearest
FFL is like two or three hours away if
he needs to give a shotgun to his cousin
who lives down the road so his cousin
can deal with like some raccoon problem
or something because of his chickens
he's gonna drive three hours with his
cousin to go fill out paperwork that's
insane and and so that's that stuff does
not work and so there's a lot of things
that are federally restricted that are
not like look for I'm not talking about
drug deals I'm talking about there are
laws putting the gun sales and there are
people who live in the middle of nowhere
who they're not going to tell you but
they don't follow any of those laws and
no one knows and no one cares and it
will not be enforced no no ATF guy is
going to drive out to a trailer 300
miles from the nearest town for a guy
who lives on 200 300 acres of worthless
property where he just entertains
himself and Minds his own business and
then bought a gun from his neighbor for
a couple hundred bucks with a private
sale they're not going to drive out
there for that I mean they might but for
the most part it's just off the grid
they can't even find it if they wanted
to yeah when it comes to the overt
communist stuff
there's not enough federal law
enforcement to deal with the size of
this country if they tried to be a
secret police that were going and
erasing people for speaking bad about
the party in cities no question in
cities we already watched people in
Staten Island get arrested because they
were saying hey don't bring these
non-citizens into our neighborhood yeah
if you live in Staten Island you're a
subject okay you're not a citizen you're
a subject for those of us that don't
live in these big cities well for the
time being we still have our freedoms
and we are not subjects
subject only to the U.S dollar well kind
of not even I mean some flight people
are trading with all sorts of things
especially in the middle of nowhere but
uh but my point is this I'm not saying
they won't try but they will not be they
the the amount of force you would need
to maintain full scale authoritarian
communist control over a country like
this yeah
the the issue here is people here are
just obstinate it's it's hard but I
agree it it would be hard but both China
and the Soviet Union were both massive
massive thinking long and hard so it's
not that it's it's not that not that I
don't think that you're you're right
about the the fact that it would be
tough but I think that what what happens
is you get violent uh coming the
government coming down violently with
the boot and then it scares people into
compliance but right so the issue is
China has a history of dynasties Russia
has monarchs the United States has
fractured colonies struggling to agree
with each other who are in Revolt first
the people who came to the United States
from Europe were people who are willing
to die to get away from whatever was
going on in their home country quite
literally like you're in the UK and
you're like this sucks can't practice my
no freedom of religion I don't want to
be here hey if you get on this boat and
ride for three months with a 20 chance
of dying you might make it to a Barren
Shore and they're like sign me up and
I'm like wow as an alternative to
conflict within your Country Escape was
an option they took it
the United States then is bread of
people who want to be left alone and
it's it's like I would still isn't our
identity you're right and listening to
you and I'm thinking but can't look at
how people have changed are we still the
you know but look at this way
take a a small cellular culture of angry
people who say don't tread on me and
then put a few drops in a big petri dish
and then watch over a month as that
whole thing spreads and you can see it
is of the same culture there's mutations
there's changes you've some other cells
have creeped into the petri dish but
it's still overwhelmingly is this one
type and it just so happens this cell is
resistance to a certain virus
that is in our blood As Americans which
is why I would not be surprised if the
immigration problem is intentional to
destroy yeah to bring in as many people
as possible who are not of the pioneer
don't tread on me ethos but they're
trying to get as many people in this
country who are of the ethos of gimme
gimme gimme I will take what I want then
it's very easy to control people when
you give them what they want to quote
Fast and the Furious 4. when the villain
says he says give the people something
that they fear losing and you can
control them well there you go well
there's only one reason why there's only
one reason why my orcas would threaten
Cubans who are coming 90 miles you know
on so uh on on a raft or about the hill
threaten opens fire on them right but
he'll let anybody pour through the
southern border from certain countries
that he particularly wants it is
Venezuelans though too yeah
it's hard though it's hard to separate
Venezuelans you know from uh the rest of
the past it is Cuban's on a boat you
know and yeah a lot of people from
Honduras and the sentiment among most of
these migrants is uh they want they want
a better life and I can I get that the
American ethos was also very similar but
the thing about the people who came here
is and there's an overlap which is why I
say I respect the people who are coming
here because they're willing to risk
death for the most part they're getting
funding there's stories about ngos
paying their bills this is very very
different big business you weren't you
weren't landing on a Barren Shore the
colonists were like we're going to land
on a Shore it's going to be hard work
and when winter comes you're probably
gonna die then too life is rough the
people who are coming here are like once
you get here you are going to live in
luxury compared to where you came from
so there's an inversion as to what the
economic what the drive is my point
ultimately is this nation is born and
bred of people who are really angry and
want to be left alone to the point where
they like are willing to die to be left
alone which means
look man
you know that the feds rated that fat
old dude's house because he was smack
talking on the internet and they killed
him
that's like that doesn't stop if this if
if the country does Go full Kami Tanki
whatever cities will be bad and they
will try to enforce thing outside of for
enforce things outside of cities but
what I think is more likely to happen
is that cities will be barred from
leaving people will yeah that's right
they'll have checkpoints around the
cities there's a bunch of sci-fi uh
movies and novels that are like this
where the people who live in the cities
very technologically advanced very
comfortable but you're not allowed to
leave and the people from outside the
cities need special permits to come into
the cities there's like a Trilogy I'm
thinking of right now because I've I've
thought the same thing that you're just
not going to be able to go and they'll
try to make it as super cushy and
comfortable for you even though it is
Draconian ah what is the name of these
but they're trilogies they wouldn't let
the Surfs leave the land but there will
be my wife's gonna kill me for not
really there will be Backwater rural
folk who are surviving on their own
that's fine and you go to a city and
they're going to stop you and be like do
you have your permit yeah do you have
your do you have your social life
there'll be stories you know what's over
that wall yeah
they're doing this in Saudi Arabia the
line that City where they're seeing they
want to build it that's yeah right
Divergent Divergent
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time